[Musique]
triomphe
[Rires]
modeste tu peux quand
même
chouou et et de gueule tu vois pas que
c'est quand je suis agressif qu'on
marche le mieux c'est
vra c'est
drôle
ouis
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouais calcul
mental c'est qui
ça delphinen patron de
Fr
réponds pas bah
devine 4e sonnerie si c'était la valise
RTL elle perdait
l'oseille je laiss un petit
message le répondeur de Delphine not
j'écoute très peu mes messages
doncit
Delphine remoi c'est cyilouna
le recordman d'audience de france
télé et et et 3 millions et et et 3
[Applaudissements]
milli excuse-moi Delphine
Delphine pourouter quel chose à votre
mess faites 5
la suite de
votre il est vraiment il est vraiment il
est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
phénomalonine j'essaie de te rappeler
avant la fin de l'émissionoun je suis en
direct j'aurais quand même aimé une
petite boîte de chocolat un petit
truc à 32% part de marché 52 % sur les
1534 52 % non mais même dans un match de
rugbyucination tu fais pas ça Delphine
et ça te coûte plus cher hein donc
maadphine rappelle-moi hein je
t'embrasse fort regarde mettez ma tête
là oh mettez enlevez Tristan balex
mettez ma tête oh là-bas non on
t'embrassephine alors il y a juste une
dringons Arca c'est que Lionel le
chauffeur de salle depuis tout à l'heure
il dit et 1 et 2 et 30 c'est un et de et
millions c'est le problème c'est le
problème c'est le problème les gars non
mais on a fait presque quatre fois le
score de TF1 à la
mêmeure va parler tout à l'heure on va
faire un gros débrief je vous c pas la
soir vous allez vous régaler là allez-y
command les gars là c'est franchement là
ce soir on travaille pour les pour les
délions là les gars là je peux vous dire
il vont avoir livraisons il vont en
avoir ce soir là vous allez vous régaler
là les gars e 4 fois TF1 6 fois M6 18
fois France 3 54 fois
[Rires]
C8
voil mal c'est ça que je veux voir voilà
c'est ça que je veux voir non mais sans
rigoler c'est incroyable c'était
incroyable
puis j'ai adoré les témoignages il y a
un gars qui aurait dit un autre gars qui
a dit un gars qui connaîtrait un gars
qui connait la grand-mère d'un gars qui
connaitt
Anouna et le gars même le gars j'ai
jamais vu ma vie veut rester anonyme
mais de ouf quoi dans l'amomima le gars
dans l'amomima ah non non c'est
incroyable moi
hier frassé là j'ai pris 200 kg dans
le j'ai arrivé là je arrivé là des
petites longueurs quand même ouais sur
la bravem à un moment j'ai décroché je
vous cache pas même moi j'ai dit bon là
c'est bon changé de chaîne ma maman j'ai
remis la clavierité qui ah tu as vu j'ai
ENI retrouver sa fille tu
vois tu parce qu'il y a pas de pub sur
france télé tu vois donc VO donc j'ai vu
la brav un peu long un peu long après il
y avait Michel Zazou on va revenir
dessus tout à l'heure aussi et puis
voilà il y a eu quoi c'était long aussi
long ouais c'était long c'était long je
vais refaire le montage les gars je
faisais moi le montage on faisait 3 et
demi non mais je vous le dis non mais
c'était sympa franchement moi quelle
belle soirée parce que des soirées comme
ça belle soir quelle belle soirée mais
je vous jure quelle belle soirée moi des
soirées comme ça ça me rappelle sais il
y avait une ambiance de tu sais quand la
France joue en demi-finale la Coupe du
Monde he tu seré il y avait un France
Maroc sans les drapeaux non mais sansc
tu vois mais moi mais même pendant le
pendant la diffusion parce qu'il y avait
des potes tout ça il a un gars il a
quand même sorti le drapeau de l'Algérie
commeis un moment il ouais il a insulté
un gars l'Algérie cont tu vois ah mais
je te jure non mais cétait incroyable
incroyable et j'arrive là je vous jure
et j'étais très très content et
d'ailleurs je vais remercier France-
télévision jeis appel d'autres personnes
de France Télévision instant pour les
remercier sur toutes les photos qu'ils
ont choisi de moi ah ouais beau gosse je
suis très content ouais très beau gosse
non franchement il il m'ont régalé ils
m'ont régalé et merci à eux et puis
moment ils ont fait comme une petite
bande
dessiné j'ai dit ah ouais ils m'ont
croqué comment on dit ils m'ont
croqué mais c'est vrai j'ai adoré ah non
non c'était incroyable alors tu sais ça
démarre déjà dès que ça
démarre Tristan Alex à mon avis il est
parti avec anidalgo à Miami bah dès qu'
a un voyage c'est avec analgo il s'est
dit tiens je vais faire un K je vais
aller à Miami il a fait le lancement de
début le plateau bonjour nous allons
parler du nouveau parrain du PAF que tu
as vu la gueule du nouveau parrain du
PAF non mais c'est vrai franchement les
gars mais regardez ça non mais
franchement regardez-moi cet
accoutrement non mais sont chariier mais
les gars c'est ça vous imaginez vous
imaginez à l'étranger quand il voit la
gueule du Parin du pas
français non mais sans déconner non mais
tu vois tu vois des gars là est-ce que
tu vois les gars là aux États-Unis he tu
vois tu as le gars là comment il
s'appelle là le gars l'animateur
américain là on homologue Jimmy Fallon
Fallon Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Fallon ils
font bat tu c'est lui le Parin du PAF il
lui montre cette photo là c'est pas Plô
un vendeur de marron
lui ah mais je te le dis non mais c'est
un truc de fou à l'étranger ils vont
dire mais il vont dire mais regardez
dans quel état il la France non mais
sans déconner là on à la COP 28 les
gars regardez attendez regardez la
gueule du Parin du
P regardez la gueule du Parin ona un
pêcheur à la
mouche non mais à l'étranger ils vont
nous jeter des pierres les gars non mais
oh ça j'espère qu'elle va pas'exporter
cette émission parce que là franchement
là je peux vous dire même au Bangladesh
tout ça là il vont dire qu'est-ce c'est
histoire c'est que ces conneries mais
franchement ça pas mal d'autres
illustration
pasétranger ah ouais ça ça en voit qu'il
était tôt le matin et puis le
casque le casque ça te compresse en
fait compress très peu de gens sont beau
goss avec des casques c'est vra vous
ferez attention à ça très peu de gens
sont beau gos avec des casques je vous
mets au défi d'être beau gosse avec un
casque tu as d'autres illustration
Patrick ah c'est ma préférée c'est ma
préférée celle-là cellelà je la mets en
fond c'est sûr consération c'est obligé
C mais je me demande même sur l'immeuble
où j'habite je vais pas faire
ass sans rigoler je vais peut-être faire
exactement la même chose comm ça tu VO
ou pas c'est incroyable franchement
c'est incroyable même la main est belle
elle est bronzée alors ça c'est la pa
alors ça c'est pas possible ça ces Paes
là il faut plus les
faire il y a rien de plus ringard que
non mais sans déconner là dis-moi
j'étais dans un j'étais dans un club de
rockab ou quoi là non mais sans déconner
il avais même une banane non mais sans
déconner la banane c'est autour du coup
c'est autour de la taille c'est pas sur
la tête tu as d'autres photos Patrick ah
c'est celle c'est ma préfér celle c'est
ma préféré c'est quand je revenais de
thaïande non non mais c'est vrai ça
franchement non non mais écoutez hier je
je vous jure je sais pas pour vous j'ai
vu alors on va voir il y a eu plein de
réaction he sur TikTok sur insta sur
Twitter et on va revenir sur toutes les
réactions parce qu'il y des trucs très
drôles mais moi mais j'ai passé une
soirée je me suis mais je vous jure
chaque minute qui passait j'étais
heureux j'étais content et je vous jure
et plus il disait des horreurs sur moi
et plus j'étais content c'est fou
j'étais heureux comme ça j'étais bienin
tu l' regardé toi bien sûr tu l' regardé
avec Laurent exactement bien sûr on
regardé tous les deux ah ouais régalé tu
vas nous raconter ah bah oui racontez ah
oui oui vous avez fait l'amour
après pendant
pendant ça c'est pendant avec toute les
images qu'on a vu pendance ça nous
inspirer non important ouais ça va ouais
il y a pas de drame là oh oh là
là tu ASAS regarder ton amie bah
évidemment je te demande pas si tu as
fait l'amour
après la réponse je connais un petit peu
ta vie tu sais hein non mais ça on a
adoré avec maman Paula tu es de retour
oui ça va pourquoi tu fais toujours des
ttés comme ça
oui j'adore tu peux bouger ta tête
t'inquiète pas ça va pa tu l'as regardé
toi aussi oui j'ai regardé en tout cas
je vois que tu m'as mis directement la
bonne place place à la potiche ouais ça
n'a rien à voir c'est pas du tout la
potiche il y a Kelly ici il y a moon
ouis il y a light il y a
coca non mais c'est pas du tout je
t'explique ça tu vois ça sypa c'est
parce qu'ils ont dit un autre truc ils
ont dit que les plus forts étaient à
droite c'est pas du tout le cas non mais
je t'expque ils ont dit que les plus
forts de la table éta à
droite copilote avec un copilote comme
ça je peux dire ccher direct crache ça
déjà première connerie ça déjà ils ont
dit la table de droite est plus forte
que la table de gauche frère oui en
terme en terme d'âge oui mais non non
non Polska alors ça va tu as regardé un
peu dire pensé oui t'inquiète c'est vrai
t'inquiète ça va toi tu es contente
d'être là oui très contente ah tu es une
chipie toi to la
chie ch elle dit que j'éta une chipie
dans le doc la chipi du PAF pas mal tu
feras un doc sur moi 3 million non non
mais je mon cardose bien sûr il a
regardé lui lui sans déconner c'est le
gars qui tweete le plus en ce
moment il doit avir il doit avoir un
pouce mon frère non mais c'est un truc
arrête un peu non mais sans déconner toi
tuas pas regardé toi tué si si j'ai
regardé sur ma tablette j'ai plus j'ai
plus l'image pas regardé on s'en fout un
peu c'est pas le donc j'ai regardais sur
ma tablette en tu étais tout seul regard
j'étais avec ma copine tu as fait
l'amour
après pas
mal moi je peux pas faire l'amour tant
que j'ai pas les scores d'audiencece
9h du matin je dis faut pas toucher à ma
ququette avant
9h allez on se retrouve dans un instant
à tout de
suite besoin de prendre